[Music]
matt rule panthers coach first year in
the nfl as a head coach after
being very successful at temple and at
baylor has teddy bridgewater as his
quarterback not a lot of people would
say that teddy bridgewater has a great
arm a strong arm a live arm now it was
his knee that derailed his career how
would you describe though the teddy
bridgewater arm strength
not great i mean it's adequate adequate
would be what i would say somewhere uh
let's see
i would say it's actually probably right
in the middle of
post-surgery chad pennington and josh
allen it's right there so that's average
right
well and i look at it this way he just
came from new orleans for a couple of
seasons where he backed up drew brees he
was 5-0 last year when brees was injured
and there have been many questions about
the ability or lack thereof of drew
brees to throw the deep ball i think
teddy bridgewater when he needs to get
it down the field he can i think he can
make the throws and he's accurate and
he's consistent and he's working with
joe brady who was an assistant with the
saints and knows teddy bridgewater and
and you know if they if they design the
offense to get the most out of what he
can do then then he it can be good
enough it doesn't need to be great he
doesn't need to throw it 80 yards he
just needs to throw it to the open guy
on a consistent basis all right we're
gonna take a quick break when we return
another nfc south quarterback has
proclaimed that he's the best
quarterback in the division we'll tell
you who and we'll give you our thoughts
when pro football talk live continues
right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports